louis robert bon jour en jour heureux de
vous rencontrer moi aussi j'ai fait
couler beaucoup d'encre a été au centre
d'une tempête j'avais perdu votre emploi
d'abord je n'ai pas de regrets d'avoir
dénoncé l'ingérence du privé dans
certains groupes de recherche
il est encore un peu tôt je me réserve
le droit de faire un bilan global de
cette expérience la plus tard pour
l'instant
ça serait hasardeux de me prononcer à ce
stade si vous trouvez qu au québec
notamment le privé les industries en
trop grand mais mis sur les agronomes
sur ce qu'on met dans nos champs
absolument
moi j'ai vécu là la problématique
j'appelle ça une problématique jumelles
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de pesticides
présentement mais il est arrivé
sensiblement la même chose dans le
domaine de fertilisation et là
maintenant avec les pesticides c'est la
même chose
les visiteurs vont recourir aux services
agronomique d'un agronome qui
connaissent ou de tout autre grenoble et
parmi ceux ci il y en a qui sont à
l'emploi des compagnies qui fournissent
ces produits là ce qui est anormal c'est
gagner un conflit d' absolument avec
vous et moi ça mais ça me tracasse ça me
préoccupe depuis 20 ans
c'est comme si les médecins étaient à
l'emploi des pharmaceutiques pour
prescrire des médicaments si on veut
faire un parallèle à peu près comme ça
est ce que le résultat c'est qu'on en
met trop haut mais pas les bons ouais
souvent on a un mec quand c'est un
dessin on augmente la dose aussi autant
dans les pesticides mais c'est encore
plus vrai dans le cas des engrais
l'équipe paraît roman c'est à dire que
les cultures où les sols ne vont pas
monter à court terme du moins d'effets
néfastes d'une dose excessive
par contre les effets d'une application
sous-optimale va paraître assez
rapidement sur le rendement des cultures
donc c'est plus facile en même temps
qu'elle dans ma note ça paraît moins
d'un an à métaux qu'est-ce que ça
produit remettre trop comme ça année
après année d'abord ça se retrouve dans
les rivières comme derrière nous les
yamaska qui est aux mains pour être
plein de pesticides qui vient de sortir
là seulement ce qu'on retourne dans les
cours d'eau là c'est pas des nids des
pesticides ni d'engrais que les plantes
les cultures ont besoin c'est ce qu'on
applique en excès
et qui se retourne dans les cours d'eau
et si on réglait la question des excès
on règlerait une grande partie entre
autres des encarts entre 80 et 90% des
concentrations en phosphates dans les
cours d'eau et en nitrates dans les
cours d'eau mais comment faire pour
régler ça alors que le centre d'études
sur les grès par exemple est contrôlé
par l'industrie c'est ça vous avez
dénoncé comme mort peut régler ça si
l'industrie partout une première étape
serait envoyer un signal clair aux
agronomes qu'on ne peut pas servir à la
fois pour un mandat spécifique servir à
la fois le vendeur d'un produit et
l'acheteur d'un produit comme c'est
écrit dans le code de déontologie alors
ça c'est une première
première étape par ménage vous dit louis
robert affaires chez les à grenoble dans
la mission de l'agronome au travail pour
l'agriculteur pour le maraîcher au
travail pop pour l'industrie absolument
les clients de l'agronome est l'entité
qui fournit la rémunération ça peut être
un client employeur ça peut être un
producteur agricole ou toute autre
organisation ou entités donc on peut pas
faire on peut pas faire les deux je suis
convaincu que si on arrivait à résoudre
cette impasse de leur réseau depuis si
longtemps beaucoup de problèmes qu'on
voit en agriculture se règlerait aussi
êtes vous satisfait des réponses
gouvernementales jusqu'ici ben moi je je
suis je suis content pour la société
québécoise en ensemble que y ait une
commission parlementaire ou encore que
la question fait ces questions là soit
étudié en commission parlementaire
parce que ça va donner une occasion
assez unique et je pense que ça va
réellement donné permettre de mettre sur
la place publique des informations très
utiles pour l'avancement de la société
du monde agricole de la société
québécoise en général louis robert
jusqu'à quel point l'industrie et
puissant
ah je pense que je pense que en termes
international et des multinationales
très puissante mais si on regarde notre
milieu relativement petit agricole je
dirais que c'est plus dans la vigilance
des institutions publiques que dans la
force des lobbys ont donc baissé les
bras ou non on les a laissés s'installer
dans des comités on a baissé les bras
edit pour reprendre le contrôle par
exemple les comités de de l'élaboration
des recommandations d'engrais au québec
vous savez que on permet aux compagnies
de siéger à peu près toutes les
les comités qui ont autorité dans
l'élaboration de recommandations d'angré
c'est assez particulier en fait ça n'a
pas de bon sens on retrouve par ailleurs
en amérique du nord
quand vous disiez ça à l'époque la au
ministère est ce que il y avait des vous
aviez des hélices qui avait déjà qu'ils
aient raison mais c'est comme ça je
pense qu'il ya une évolution et on s'en
va faire un règlement de cette chose là
et c'est une des raisons pourquoi je me
présente comme la présidente de l'ordre
des agronomes c'est de mettre les choses
claires pour tous les agronomes lula
baer a terminé ce que vous passez
retrouver votre emploi je ne sais pas
l'avenir le dira je vais allez vous
battre jusqu'au bout
je vais présentement c'est un cours et
on verra les conclusions je veux laisser
aller les choses je peux malheureusement
pas aller dans les détails à cette
situation là mais vous seul vous
aimeriez un jour retrouver cet emploi là
oui c'est certain mais pour l'avenir à
court terme la possibilité que je dirige
l'ordre des agronomes me plaît
énormément lu robert merci on va suivre
là c'est un mot d'intérêt merci